字幕: Kirara Muramatsu
校正: Harue Mori
デザインというと
多くの人が思い浮かべるのは
おしゃれなパッケージ
スタイリッシュなプロダクト
ポスターにweb
そのほとんどが 見た目のデザイン
であるように思います
それも もちろんデザインです
しかし 良い見た目を作ることが
全てではありません
より良い何か
立場や対象は多様であれ
それを作り出すことが デザインだと
私は考えています
時に 見た目だけでなく
人々の行動や心理も
デザインの対象となり得ます
1970年代 ニューヨーク
治安の悪さは全米最悪とも言われた時代
中でも地下鉄は 落書きだらけで
汚い 暗い 危険
犯罪の巣窟だとも言われていました
ところが 2000年になると
その負のイメージは一変
立役者となったのは 宇田川信学
という 一人のデザイナー
彼は 40年ぶりに導入される
新車両のデザインを一任され
当時 薄暗くて 落書きだらけだった
車両を一新しました
白を基調とした照明と壁で
空間全体を明るい印象に
床は黒色
粒子状の模様をちりばめて
汚れが目立ちづらいように
ドア付近の座席の手すりには
斜めに仕切りを入れて
電車を乗り降りする際に
頻繁に起こっていた
ひったくりやスリを防ぐように
明るくて 清潔感のある空間で
しかも ひったくりはしづらい
そうとなれば そもそも
落書きをしようという気も
犯罪を起こそうという気も
抑えられることでしょう
彼は「人々の行動を
デザインの力でより良く変えたい」
との思いで車両をデザインし
実際 人々の行動は変わりました
地下鉄内での犯罪の発生率は
８割も減少
イメージも回復
住人も 観光客も
安心して使えるようになりました
彼は 言葉を使うでもなく
武力行使に頼るでもなく
デザインの力で より良い社会を
作り出したのです
彼の仕事を知った当時
私は高校３年生
何の気なしにつけていたテレビで
彼のインタビューを目にして
デザイナーは
そんなことまで考えているのか
デザインには そんな力
人の心理や行動さえも
変えうる力があるのかと
衝撃を受けました
それからというもの
電車に乗るたびに
それまで意識の向いていなかった
壁や床の色 座席の形
人々の行動にも
目がいくようになりました
たった30分
たった30分の番組で
デザインというものの
ほんのかすかな一端を知っただけで
私の意識は 世界は
大きく 確実に変わりました
かつて 教育哲学者の林竹二が
「学んだことの証しは ただ一つで
何かがかわることである」
という言葉を残しました
その学びの本質のようなものを 楽しさを
私は一瞬のうちに体感したのです
そして もっとデザインについて
深く知ったら
そうしたら 世界は
もっともっと楽しくなるんじゃないか
そう思いました
学びたい 知りたい
そう強く感じたのは
好奇心が無性に駆られたのは
その時が 初めてだったように思います
デザイナーになりたかったから ではなく
デザインについて
もっと学びたかったから
その単純な好奇心に従い
私は大学で デザインを
勉強することに決めました
それまで考えていた
進路を白紙撤回して
大学で４年間 デザインを学び
実際どうだったか
それはもう すごく楽しかったです
日々新しい知識を学び
毎日 気づき 発見が多い
めくるめく日々を送りました
そして 私の世界は
さらに大きく変わりました
こんな風に変わったという例を一つ
この会場に 全裸の方は
いないはずなので
皆さんが身につけている
服を例としてみます
馴染みのショッピングモールに行き
新しい服を買いに行く場面
ちょっと想像してみてください
ショップの外観やレイアウト
そこで買い物をしている
他のお客さん 店員さん
モールの入り口から
そのショップに行くまでの 道中にあるお店
思い浮かべることはできるでしょうか？
馴染みのショッピングモールといえども
なかなかに難しいことだと思います
こんな風に 私たちが普段認識している
意識しているのは
世界のごくごく一部です
そこにあるのに 見えていない 意識の外
それはもはや
存在していないも同然です
これがデザインを学び出すと
意識の向く対象は グーンと広がります
例えば 先のショッピングモールを
例にすれば
商品の一つ一つはもちろん
店内に使われている色
色の組み合わせ
棚やディスプレイのデザイン
プライスカードの一つ一つにまで
意識が向くようになります
さらには このお店は
このくらいの年代の この性別で
こんな雑誌を読んでる人を
ターゲットにしているな
きっと あそこで買い物している
あのお客さんは
あのブランドも
あんなタイプの雑貨も好きだろうな
なんていう風に見えてくるんです
自分のタイプじゃないからと
スルーしていたお店も
ここは 一体どんな人に向けた
お店なんだろうかと
想像を巡らせる対象となってきます
自分の身につけた知識をもとに
こんな風に推測や想像を巡らせていくのは
さながらシャーロックホームズのようで
なかなかに楽しいものです
そのちょっとした楽しさを
日々味わえるだけでも
デザインを学んでよかったなと
私は思います
服に限らず 今皆さんが身につけている
腕時計やアクセサリーなど
普段使っているノートやペン
そして それらのパーツ 一つ一つも
私たちの世界を構築している
無数のモノたち全て
誰かしらの手によって
デザインされています
デザインを学び
その身の回りのモノたちに 一歩
一歩近付いてみる
歩み寄ってみると
それぞれの色や形
機能に込められた 愛や情熱であったり
商品を買わせるための戦略であったり
企業やつくり手 デザイナーの
様々な 意図や想いに意識が向き
想像を巡らすことができるようになります
すると
普段 気にも留めていなかった
モノたちの輪郭が
ぼんやりとした世界の一部だった
風景の一部だったモノたちが
くっきりと見えてきます
すると 目に映る世界は
広く 面白く 味わい深いものになり
何気ない日常の一場面も
なんだか楽しいものになってくるはずです
また デザインを学ぶ というのは
デザインをしていくうえで
必要となってくる
様々な幅広い知識
そして その応用の仕方
それを学ぶことでもあります
その応用の対象を
自分の日常に向ければ
日々の暮らしを より良くする
そんなことも できてしまいます
デザインの力で
社会がより良くなるなら
自分の些細な日常を
ちょっと良くすることくらい
お手の物のはずです
例えば デザインの基本要素でもある色
色の知識
色が持つそれぞれのイメージや心理効果を
知識として持っていれば
朝 服を選ぶ時に
今日は仕事の打ち合わせだから
信頼感を与えたい
じゃあ 重めのトーンで寒色系
紺色の服を着ていこう であったり
今日はカジュアルな交流会だから
親しみやすさを感じてもらうために
明るめの暖色系
黄色やオレンジあたりの服で行こうかな
といった具合に
自分が相手に与える印象を
ちょっとだけ自分の思い通りに
自分に有利にできたり
時には 自分の気持ちを落ち着かせたり
高ぶらせたりも
他にも色の知識は
日々のごはんを
ちょっと美味しそうに
見せることもできちゃいます
例えば チキンでもポークでも
お肉のグリル料理を作ると
なんだか全体的に茶色っぽくて
美味しそうに見えない
そんな時には トマトとズッキーニ
パプリカも一緒に焼いて
盛り付けの器は紺色
仕上げにレモンを添えてみてください
デザイン的な言葉で言えば
色相 色数を増やして
重めのトーンで画面を締める
アクセントに補色を加える
といったところでしょうか
それだけでも ごはんは
ちょっと美味しそうに見えてきます
他にも レイアウトの知識があれば
ノート作り 資料作りに
応用することもできます
見やすいノートで
勉強の効率が良くなったり
仕事をしていくうえでも
営業の資料や内部資料が
見やすい 伝わりやすいに
越したことはないですよね
そんな 日常の些細なことも
すべて立派なデザインだと 私は思います
そして その日常を
自分の手でちょっと良くできる
そのデザインの力は
誰しもが持っていても
いいものではないのかなと 思うのです
皆さんの中には
特にファッションや料理に関しては
感覚的にできてしまう人も
多いのではないかと思います
その感覚的なものを
知識として学ぶと
ある程度 公式化 マニュアル化を
することができるようになります
学べば学ぶほど 自分の手札は増え
日常の中で
あれ この公式って ここにも使えるな
という場面が増えます
応用の幅
ちょっと良くできる物事が
だんだん多くなるのです
私自身はその対象が
自分の日常から
自分の生まれ育った地域
伊豆修善寺へとなり
地元をデザインの力で
ちょっと良くしたい
その思いで 2017年
大学４年生の時に
『修善寺燕舎』という
地域密着型のデザインスタジオと
直営の物販店舗を
修善寺の温泉街に構えました
これまでの２年間は 日々店頭に立ち
地域の方々や観光客の皆さんの声を聞き
地元らしさ感じるお土産物のデザイン
地域在住の作家を結びつけての
商品のプロデュースをしたり
野外手づくり市や 訪日外国人に向けた
和食の料理教室などのイベント
その企画と 関連するツールのデザイン
そして実際の運営に取り組んできました
２年経った今でも
地元のおじいちゃん おばあちゃんからは
「雑貨屋さんの店長さん」
もしくは「絵を描いていることを
仕事にしている子」
そんな風に思われています
それも仕事の一部ではありますが
人の流れ お金の流れを常に見据え
地域に根ざした
ことづくり ものづくりで
地域の活性化をそっと支えていく
地域そのものを デザインしていく
ちょっと良くしていく
それが私の仕事です
もちろん デザインを学んだからこそ
今はデザイナーとして仕事をしています
しかし かつての私自身が
そうであったように
デザインを学ぶ ということは
デザイナーになる方法を学ぶ ということと
決してイコールではありません
デザインを学ぶと 目に映る世界は
広く 面白く 味わい深いものになります
そして 自分の日常を 明日を
ちょっと良くできる
そんな素敵な力を
手に入れることもできてしまいます
そして その素敵なデザインという力は
デザイナーと呼ばれる
一握りの人が使えるような特殊な力ではなく
誰にでも あなたにでも
手にできる力です